juste un mot on peut revenir sur l'idée
d'une assemblée dans laquelle la
majorité présidentielle n'aurait pas la
majorité absolue s'cusez moi je
n'insiste mais ça voudrait dire que vous
soyez votre groupe là nul serait le
premier groupe ou première intergroupe
d'opposition
et donc vous aurez un rôle d'arbitrage
très fort et que dans cette perspective
là il ya un stand de texte qui pourrait
être négocié pied à pied avec chaque
composante des groupes est-ce que ça
c'est pas un risque de voir votre
coalition la nouvelle union populaire
explosé très vite et se divise et très
vite au sein de l'assemblée sur les sur
des textes avec des écologistes qui
dirait oui au gouvernement pas vous et
puis un versement sur d'autres textes
des divans jeudi divergences de vue avec
les communistes et les socialistes
savait elle va tout autrement dit m elle
va durer cette nouvelle union populaire
au sein d'assemblées ou pas moi je
dirais que c'est comme le vélo ça tient
debout tant que ça avance si on en
souffre et rires mais c'est une belle
image est ce que je veux dire c'est que
si si cette coalition apparaît comme en
dynamique en capacité de prendre le
pouvoir prochainement qu'on est qu'on a
raté la victoire de peu et c'est avec un
intérêt à maintenir je suis persuadé que
toutes les composantes de la nouvelle
union populaire pourront les conditions
de projection pour y avoir deux voire
trois fois plus de députés que les
autres composantes du coup vous allez
être vraiment enclin à faire des
compromis oui oui non moi je moi je
pense qu'il faut que ce que nous avons
fait là je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est un tournant stratégique depuis
l'élection présidentielle et je pense
que nous l'avons fait et il la c1 c'est
un tournant qui ne va pas s'arrêter au
lendemain de l'élection de toute manière
donc on va être contraint et c'est pas
qu'une contrainte d'ailleurs de discuter
politiquement moi ce que vous dites est
une hypothèse mais je ne crois pas que
mes amis socialistes gym et le mot amis
entre guillemets parce que parfois on
s'est un peu confrontés mais malgré tout
on s'est découvert aussi moi j'ai
apprécié olivier fond dans cette
campagne qui est un homme de qualité bon
je ne crois pas que nos amis socialistes
voient leur rôle désormais pour être le
supplétif de macron pour mettre en place
des textes moi je pense que la tendance
de ce que vous décrivez mais là tous les
deux on fait des hypothèses c'est plutôt
que le groupe elle risque d'être absorbé
de plus en plus dans la majorité macro
nist parce que c'est la logique des
choses c'est plutôt ça qui va avoir lieu
est quelque part pour ceux qui
s'intéressent aux idées politiques la
disparition de ce qu'était la droite
traditionnelle qui va re le maquereau
nîmes va devenir l'agout le grand parti
de droite et du centre à mon avis il
faudrait un bon point
[Musique]